[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute eine 20
minuten aubin kerber tat und nowak
deswegen weil es draußen total heiß ist
die hitzewelle ist wieder da und hab ich
gedacht nein denn offen bleibt aus das
will ich euch nicht antun und die
zutaten sind auch sehr überschaubar tat
übrigens deswegen weil wir das heute in
einer tat vormachen werden nicht da hat
er nimmt einfach eine springform mit der
durchmesser größe 26 ansonsten ist es
aber auch kein problem denn sie bekommt
in meinem shop verlinke ich euch unten
in die infobox hier sind die zutaten
ihr nehmt einmal eure lieblings kekse
dann butter für den boden die ist
bereits geschmolzen kalte schlagsahne
hier habe ich magath beck und doppel
rahmen frischkäse außerdem eine bio
zitrone sahne fest für die creme vanille
extrakt und puderzucker und natürlich
erdbeeren und weil der hansa gerade noch
für mich die erdbeeren eingekauft hat
und weiß noch was die mit gekauft hast
jetzt ganz raffaello du weißt gar nicht
dass ich deine waffe hätte man wirklich
benutzt werde
wenn man besuch hat man so schön auf dem
tisch stunden aber ich finde erdbeeren
und raphael passt auch richtig gut
zusammen oder da machen wir das okay
doch jetzt geht es an die zubereitung
für den boden ich traue mir alles weg
und an demonstriert die knicks habe ich
jetzt richtig schön fein gemahlen und
ihr könnt das ganze natürlich auch mit
der hand machen einfach in einen beutel
geben und mit dem nudelholz obendrauf
ja genau stressbewältigung und dann gebe
ich dir geschmolzene butter dazu und das
ist auch schon der fertige boden so
einfach jetzt nur noch um rühren nehmen
aber hier jeden rest machen wir sonst
mehr hinter der kamera
ja unser gibt findet richtig schönen tag
sauber nachdem wir dann die tat vom
richtig schön mit den pics boden
ausgekleidet habt und auch richtig schön
an gedrückt habe gibt ihr das in den
kühlschrank aber auch nur bis zur
weiterverarbeitung wenn wir machen jetzt
gleich die kleben die dauert auch nur 56
minuten und in der zeit ist es eben gut
wenn alles schön fest im kühlschrank
sollen jetzt geht es weiter mit der
creme und ich habe ihr versprochen dass
die auch super schnell geht
ich gebe jetzt ganz einfach alle zutaten
die hier stehen rein das sind ja alle
bis auf die erdbeeren die kommen nämlich
gleich für die deko erst haben dass
raffael was natürlich zu dem doppel raum
für stille und den markt ihr könnt die
verhältnisse auch variieren hauptsache
ihr habt am ende eben die 500 gramm
[Musik]
ich bin uns heute meine hand spielgerät
und sehr deutlich das ganze jetzt hier
schön zusammen vergebe ich auch bis
seine fans mit dazu und das gute ist
dadurch dass susanne fest mit rein gibt
könnt ihr das direkt weiter verwerten
ihr müsst den kuchen dann auch nicht
kühl stellen deswegen ist auch ein 20
minuten rettete
dass dort jetzt auch nur fünf minuten
gleich den wir alles nur noch auf den
boden und dann ist auch noch wert ist
[Musik]
bevor ich jetzt die deko machen müssen
wir dass er hier nur noch rauskriegen
und jetzt fragt euch wahrscheinlich
kiwis in gottes namen willst du das
herauskriegen ist verrate ich euch so
nehme ich das einfach anheben
hier gibt es nämlich so einfach im boden
dem man annehmen kann dann ist es auch
gar nicht mehr schwer kurz die hand weg
sind und jetzt brauchte irgendetwas ganz
flach es am besten
irgendein torten retter wie hier zum
beispiel seien hier zum beispiel oder
ihr nehmt euch das mache ich immer am
liebsten ganz einfach eine dünne schmale
sinke palette und dann könnte auch die
platte untendrunter entfernen
[Musik]
und fertig ist die 20 minuten erdbeer
raffaello tat habe euch nur ein tipp
achtet darauf dass die mutter schön
ausgehärtet ist ja meistens reichen da
wirklich zehn minuten im kühlschrank und
dann könnt ihr das auch ganz einfach
anheben wie es gerade bei mir gesehen
habt ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen nachbacken
darf ich heute nicht sagen also ganz
viel freude beim zubereiten und beim
essen wenn dies wirklich sehr
erfrischend sehr cremig lecker und vor
allem durch die ihr durch diesen keks
boden übrigens noch so ein bisschen sagt
man ja knusprig also knusprig kann man
dazu nicht sagen
und dann hoffe ich dass sie diesen video
and deutschen nach oben gibt main kanal
natürlich kostenlos abonniert wenn ihr
das nicht schon längst getan hat
aktiviert auf jeden fall auch die glocke
dann verpasst ja auch kein weiteres
video mehr
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal auf die sketch in
tschechien
[Musik]